you know we we were talking about
biohacking versus
natural living earlier and i think we've
really highlighted the fact that you can
harness benefits from kind of having one
foot
planted in the realm of ancestral
science and another foot planted in the
realm of of modern science
and i think that combining the two you
know combined both biohacking and
natural living is really ultimately a
good way
to live a long time and feel good doing
it and so if you are
eating healthy based on some of the
nutritional principles and testing that
i've outlined
if you're moving well which we didn't
address but it essentially involves you
know
low level physical activity throughout
the day sometimes lifting heavy stuff
occasionally sprinting whether via
tennis or soccer or
on an air dyne or whatever else and i do
doing some amount of mobility you know
some stretching some foam rolling it's
really not that complex to
to move well i think walking is the most
underrated activity of
all movements but let's assume you're
eating well and you're moving healthy
then i think ninety percent of the
additional benefit
comes from just charging up your body's
battery you know i'll throw two more
books at you
the body electric by robert becker and
healing is voltage by jerry tennant both
excellent books
which dictate the fact that as i alluded
to earlier and i was talking about the
airplane
your cells operate with a proper
electrochemical balance
across the membrane your cells operate
like a like a battery with a slight
negative charge on the inside of that
membrane
and a slight positive charge on the
outside and there are certain things
that can keep that battery
charged that a lot of people i think who
are eating well
and moving well neglect and that would
be
a good water and mineral intake which
helps to carry these charges such as the
minerals
through your body right so i personally
drink pure clean
structured filtered water and use
copious amounts of really good minerals
not just table salt right but
but really good salts like celtic salt
and black cone of salt and kalima salt
and trace liquid minerals so
my body's constantly getting the the
minerals that carry the electrolytes
and the electrical energy into it you
charge up
those electrons with photons of light
from things like
infrared panels or sunlight or an
infrared sauna
you go outside barefoot or get outside
in the ocean or on the beach
with your shoes off or even wearing some
of these grounding or earthing shoes we
talked about or the type of pad that
you're using right now danica
so that you're actually getting exposed
to the negative ions
and electrical impulses from the planet
earth
and then you throw in some heat and some
cold to move this electricity through
your body
and i mean gosh if you if you eat well
eating a diet that's customized to you
you move naturally and then you get uh
water minerals earthing
sunlight heat and cold and cold
guarantee you're gonna feel amazing
you're gonna feel amazing yeah yeah
maybe finish up by giving um
giving us that sort of like level one
version of
say i wanna get up in the morning and i
wanna have
i wanna burn fat i wanna um i wanna feel
energized i want to
work the inside of me a little bit to
recover whatever could be going on
inside
on a cellular level and have energy um
like what would be
sort of the the movement and maybe the
nutritional consumption like what would
the quit what would the morning look
like for someone going to work
i'm going to challenge myself in the
next 60 seconds i'm going to be going to
give you the whole day
wake up take care of your spirit with
some form of
meditation journaling prayer breath work
anything that optimizes that most
important part of you
your soul first while you're in a fasted
state go out
get some sunlight preferably outside do
something for
20 to a maximum of 40 minutes right just
move in that fasted state
come back take a cold shower
start your day eat your breakfast
mindfully
take little breaks throughout the day to
walk to move hang from pull-up bars
swing kettlebells
and be productive creative and impactful
with
whatever your your purpose in life is
take a nap in the mid afternoon or a
quick meditation session if you can
to get a little decrease in stress and
cortisol in the middle of the day
continue throughout the day some time
before dinner lift some weights or do a
little high intensity cardio
to get your body ready to be able to
receive food and
burn glucose well have dinner don't be
carb phobic at dinner
eat real food for all your meals but
include some extra carbs at dinner
start to decrease technology screen time
work stress etc
preferably an hour or more before bed
close your eyes in bed return to the
gratitude
the journaling the breath work the care
for your soul to book end the day
and fall asleep wake up the next day
rinse wash and repeat that's where i
start
thank you i have a feeling that uh that
is still an adjustment for many
probably